for you
getting locked up getting out of jail
bouncing back do you think that you
going
going back in like like for the extended
amount of time do you think you came out
a better person like more humbled
maybe a different perspective on how to
look at everything yeah definitely
i'm saying definitely changing my
perspective on life in general you know
what i'm saying my music career just
every everything i like
cause you got nothing but time to think
in there right it's like not really
because she
is so much [ __ ] going on you know what
i'm saying but at the same time
you dig when i'm saying hell nah ain't
no time to think
yeah so you got out you just you know
because i feel like we got a new i feel
like we got a new
so like a new guy when you got out no
it's definitely you know what i'm saying
definitely you know what i'm saying
definitely it definitely changed me
though you seem more focused
you seem very very like on just on your
[ __ ] like at the end of the day like
people want to want to fire from you you
know what i'm saying like and i feel
like sometimes the antics got a little
out of control to where people weren't
checking for your music as much as they
were checking for your antics
not for sure and i think i've said that
in interviews before because i've talked
to some of these young kids
who are known for that i'd be like hey
look like you know what i'm saying like
you want you you want the music to be
first now obviously you're different
because you're kind of a cultural icon
right you can get your twitch bag you
could go act you could
you could do to do whatever you want but
like the root of all of it is the music
right you know what i'm saying so i feel
like ever since since you've you've been
out you've been focused on that
yeah i've been locked in studio every
day like
every day every day every day every day
every day i can't wait to hear what i
got coming next like you know
so i was just like man musically man bro
i got some
some stuff coming and it's fun i love to
see the people dance i love to see the
reaction i love to see the streams like
i love it you know what i'm saying so
it's like i want people just think like
i'm just coming with
a hit and then i'm gonna dip off again
and like like this the career just my
career like it's
[ __ ] i'm just getting started